los países de la Unión Europea y desde
aquí Bruselas también lugar de la sede
de la otan se está siguiendo con suma
atención todos los acontecimientos en
Rusia precisamente la otan asegura que
está monitorizando la situación también
las instituciones de la Unión Europea se
están coordinando con sus Aliados del g7
precisamente el jefe de la diplomacia
europea Joseph se ha reunido de urgencia
por videoconferencia con los ministros
de exteriores de los países del g7 de
hecho además los cancilleres europeos se
reúnen también el próximo lunes en una
reunión que ya estaba prevista De
antemano pero que sin duda toma un nuevo
Matiz tras esta rebelión desatada por el
líder de Los mercenarios Wagner además
borré Ya informado que ha activado el
centro de respuesta de crisis europea
para evaluar la situación de seguridad
en los 27 aún así desde las
instituciones europeas se insiste que lo
que está ocurriendo en es un asunto
puramente interno pero si bien es cierto
que todos los líderes europeos que se
están pronunciando al respecto sobre la
situación en Rusia también añaden su
apoyo inquebrantable a Ucrania pase lo
que pase todos los países europeos
también están anunciando que se reúnen
sus gabinetes de crisis por ejemplo
Bélgica lo reúne mañana de urgencia el
Primer Ministro del país Alexander de
croa ASUME que la situación es seria y
es grave y por su parte también los
países bálticos que están muy cercanos a
Rusia y han anunciado el refuerzo de su
frontera